[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
open the doors hello hello everybody and
welcome welcome to daily with Doc I
think we've got everything figured out
today folks for those of you who have
been following us and having so much
Divine patience we greatly appreciate
you as you know sometimes
we just have to love technology because
it works great summertime or most of the
time but not all the time so welcome
welcome
to daily with Doc if you are watching us
out
in the internet live stream World
somewhere and you would like to join us
live you are more than welcome to at
Daily with
doczoom.com so come on over in this
space you are able to raise your hand
and ask Dr wallet questions and we will
get you the questions in the order that
the hands are raised we also have people
that are putting questions in the chat
so I am able to see them on YouTube and
Rumble and if I get to the right screen
Facebook but I have some amazing
co-hosts because they're watching these
also
so that whenever somebody out on one of
those spaces has a question then
hopefully if the time allows because if
you have questions raise your hand early
ask your questions early so that we can
get to your questions
um
because yeah it's
it's crazy how fast time goes by so I
just want to say hello to AJ out on
YouTube who is helping keep control of
that chat and letting us know when we
have questions there answering the ones
that he knows the answers to and
forwarding them to us on the ones that
he doesn't or the ones that really do
need Dr wallach's recommendations
because folks we are so very very
blessed to be able to have one of the
founding fathers of the science of
epigenetics and how he got to be one of
those founding fathers is through his
life experience and then his education
and
work experience as a researcher as a
pathologist as a veterinarian as a
teacher of nutrition at a university
level and as a naturopathic physician Dr
Wallach has all of these hats that he
has worn over the years and he still
wears all of them today as he brings
messages of Hope and empowerment to us
here on daily with Doc now daily with
Doc is sponsored by dailywitdoc.com
which myself and my team are part of the
group of independent youngevity
Associates who are associated with the
daily wood dog team
if you are invited by somebody specific
please make sure that you get back with
them whether you're here live with us or
watching the replay doesn't matter get
back with the person that shared this
program with you because they cared
enough they heard something within our
message that brought you to their mind
so make sure that you get back to them
and take Serious that they recommended
this program to you because chances are
you have been through so much
going to from appointment to appointment
to appointment and not getting better
and even adding more and more labels and
pharmaceutical bottles to your everyday
needs
well folks
we aren't chemical deficient
warm nutrient deficient and when we meet
those needs the needs for other things
start to diminish and I am so excited to
be able to share this message with you
because that's exactly what happened for
me so
folks raise your hand early if you have
questions put it in the chat raise your
hand let us help you find that better
path to a different Health Journey that
is not uphill struggle folks it's an
uphill to
Thrive not just survive so Dr Wallach
just want to say hello and let me check
something real quick if I may please
um I'm gonna check and do just a back up
recording
just in case
recording in progress so thank you for
that and I'm glad we have it going so Dr
Wallach go ahead and I'm going to have
you join me here on the screen hello and
welcome to daily with dog doc well thank
you thank you Becca and thank you for
your entire team I'm just really always
impressed with all these great great
individuals and um
we had a lot of good stuff going on of
course today we're going to talk about
arthritis osteoporosis but before we get
to the subject of the day it was a very
interesting announcement on Fox news
today
um by the UFC here Albert Einstein
College of Medicine a professor there a
lady Professor by the name of Lauren
Roth said and I've been saying this for
years you know me I've been saying for
years gender issues and all this stuff
going on with little boys just think
they're girls and little girls think
they're boys these issues start before
the baby is born
what actually starts before the baby is
conceived okay and it's one of those
things where
um the this is on Fox news this morning
okay and so it goes along with what I've
been thinking for 25 years and so now I
can open my mouth a little bit because
I'm just you know agreeing with a
college professor here who came to the
same conclusions I did 25 years ago in
veterinary medicine It's Not Unusual in
history to have cows that thought they
were bulls and Bulls that thought they
were cows and and so forth and they're
called free Martins okay and uh if they
had a cow that thought she was a bull
and chasing all the cows trying to have
sex with them they would just knock her
in the head and turn her into steaks and
ribs and that kind of stuff then they
had bulls that thought they were
chasing of uh all the boys okay instead
of the girls they just knocked them in
the head and took them and eat them but
that was a long time ago once they
started putting vitamins and minerals
into their Alfalfa pellets
okay instead of just throwing hay at him
and corn and stuff like that making it
gotten a little more serious about the
nutritional needs
all that disappeared so I knew that the
same thing had to be true for humans
because we saw in just every species of
animals you could think of and so
is I'm very excited about this and we do
have
some products that can help here we have
zerofem
for little girls that think they're boys
okay starting out with like a half of
one tablet a day grind it up in some
applesauce and give it and it doesn't
hurt to give one dose a day of our kids
toddy also which is a good tasting
orange juice tasting liquid meal
replacement for kids don't forget to
throw in the efa's they have essential
Penny acids and then
um
I think we're going to have Miracles
same thing with the boys the boys need
the zero test
okay who the boys think they're girls
they can have zero test I think we can
reroute them and little girls that think
they're boys we can give them zero Femme
and reroute them so I'm just excited
about the potential here
and we'll I'm gathering evidence and so
forth and we will have a great great
program here in the near future just
totally on that subject but getting to
the subject of the day unless you had a
comment or another question on that
well no Dr Wallach yeah actually I do
have a question on that because xerifem
and Zara test they are powerful yes when
it comes grind it up in some applesauce
well and I like the fact that you said
just half a tablet would that be based
on weight
well it's just starting because we're
talking usually these kids that have a
misdirection of gender they start
showing it when they're anywhere from
two to four years old
it's not just when they're a teenager
okay and um this is what just really
disrupts families and gets them all in a
dither and so forth and rightfully so
because
you know
Judy
wants to play basketball with the boys
well there's nothing wrong with that no
but she thinks she's a boy okay and so
forth you know she wants to go go
urinate standing up like the boys do and
all that kind of stuff and and she wants
to chase the girls like the boys do and
she's only four years old and so these
are the sort of things I believe we can
turn around very quickly by getting rid
of all the bad stuff they have to be
able to absorb all this stuff get them
on you know the 90th Century chances
according to their body weight the kids
toddy the um
in the efas and then of course
um don't forget
don't forget the um
for the girls who think they're boys and
is there a test for the boys to think to
girls and I believe we're gonna be able
to just reverse this whole thing because
it's not a genetic thing it's not on
immune it's not something terrible is
happening at the moment it happened much
much earlier but it is a nutritional
deficiency it's easily
um reversed I believe we've reverse it
in animals and I believe we can reverse
it in people
well I love the fact Dr well like that
we can support
every one of
one of where we're at
we can be
whichever direction it is that's correct
so that's it that's what I love the fact
the most Dr Wallach is meeting people
where they're at supporting them where
they're at
but if there's a poor health condition
like Bone and Joint issues and people
looking at having to have joint
replacements
Dr Wallach there's a lot that we can do
so share with us about that okay I've
got that one right here okay
okay why am I having Becca put up the
wallet Revolution because the person who
wrote the forward to the book is a very
famous movie actor and singer Pat Boone
had terrible arthritis and osteoporosis
and all the doctors want to give him a
double knee replacement double hip
replacement and somebody introduced him
to me
um and we um got him on our healthy
boner joint packet very quickly
we regroup his knees and his hips and he
never had to have a surgery well when he
learned we were putting this book
together
he wrote the forward of the book now he
tells his story we're talking four or
five pages here this isn't just a
paragraph This is quite a story that Pat
Boone wrote the beginning of the book on
his arthritis
and of course uh it's one of those
things where I worked with so many
athletes over the years famous athletes
that had arthritis osteoporosis it was
going to end their careers I rebuilt
them they came back and did wonderful
things and of course
um I do I what should I say was able to
and in doing all that I was able to get
rid of of um things like cisier brosis
which is a birth defected kids thought
to be genetic I worked with Jerry Lewis
was able to get rid of muster this fee
it's thought to be a genetic disease in
kids no we got rid of that very quickly
with a nutritional program and then also
uh the son of a dead syndrome SIDS uh
there was a kid
um die this weekend okay he was a a um
Louisiana University uh swimming
medalist okay 18 years old and he just
dropped dead just walking and she was
the classes and just dropped in okay at
18 years of age well this is the same
thing that kills babies with sediment
death syndrome part of the heart disease
and that's why we have from CD I'll put
that up here the CD set calls
there's a new Bull in town there you go
because
Red Bull has only one mineral in it
magnesium
are rebound has 75 minerals in it okay
if there's three CDs in this set CD one
is let's see here dead athletes don't
lie
CD number two
is
let's see here CD number two is oh those
billionaires what no that's City number
three
c number two exercise exercise
yeah there you go
and um because everybody says well he
exercised he drank plenty of water and
rehydrated well guess what when you're
sweating from exercise or work guess
what you're not just sweating out water
you're just running out of soup if all
the nutrients particularly minerals in
your body just lick your arm when you're
sweating yeah it tastes like salt right
that's because it was funny nutrients if
you're just rehydrating with water
you're in trouble and that's why
billionaires died 66. professional
athletes Olympic athletes in America
their life expectancy
is 56.7
billionaires in America their life
expectancy 66.3
okay and so arthritis cost us
in America just just to treat the
symptoms not to remember a trip or just
treat the symptom arthritis America cost
us each year
626.8 billion dollars
osteoporosis each year classes America
just to treat the symptoms not to to
prevent it or cure it 2.3 trillion so
together it's three trillion dollars
we're spending each year to deal just
with the symptoms of arthritis
osteoporosis
and diabetes only cost us 342 billion
dollars a year heart disease only the
316 billion dollars a year
okay
and so we have a lot of work to do to
get the information out there because we
already know the cause of mentioned cure
of arthritis we know the causing cure
osteoporosis and of course my favorite
my favorite osteoporosis is all in your
head
and I think you've got one of those
books in a CD that we did also
there you go and page number six page
number six has got the
um pictures of the normal skeletal
quadrant inch thick and the osteoporosis
goal which is an inch and a half to two
inches six squeezing the spinal cord
there's 37 different diseases you get
when you have osteoporosis of the skull
and they don't teach this in medical
school and so that's why we wrote the
book and got the CD set put together and
right now it's one of the most popular
books being ordered from our our
bookstore
is it's on your head because people have
these problems
and the you know doctors say to women
who get up five times a night ten times
a night to urinate well you must have a
prostate problem let's do a biopsy and
the women will tilt their head and say
the doctor are you kidding I'm a girl I
don't have a prostate gland oh oh oh I'm
sorry okay because they're always
sinking down that track okay
as opposed to listening to the patient
and so it's on your head covers 37
different diseases that are called
osteoporosis called squeezing to 12
pairs of cranial nerves and also
squeezing the spinal cord okay it's all
reversible all preventable not genetic
not immune just simple nutritional
deficiencies so we've been doing
Miracles all over the world it's a
popular book all over the world now so
we're considering we have to see what
languages are best we do have the CD in
English and be one of the first ones
because we could translate the CD into
eight or nine or ten languages very
quickly so let's do that Rebecca let's
like we did with Dead Doctors Don't Lie
we've got that in nine languages let's
do that let's get this as uh translated
it's all in your head into eight or nine
languages on CDs okay that'll be the
quickest way to do it we can do that in
fact I know that the book itself is
already in process of being translated
into Spanish well I will work on Spanish
for the CD as well
um and I know just the person to do it
but Dr Wallach share with me how does
it's all in your head relate to Joint
issues
okay well because when you have actually
approaches to the skull
and TMJ which is arthritis of the jaw
joint it's the same thing that deals
with your knees and your hips and your
shoulders and your fingers your
vertebrae okay because when you get
osteoporosis
in your
um
and arthritis your little finger in your
right hand thank you
it's in every bone in your body it's not
a local thing it's a it's a uniform
Universal thing in your body when you
get obviously approaches and arthritis
any places you can just bet your boots
it's in every joint and every bone in
the body
and so
um you know when you look at how badly
the doctors have missed it there is a
heart irregularity called atrial
fibrillation afib and their cure for
AFib
is to anesthetize you cut your chest
open take your heart out take a branding
iron hot and touch it to your heart all
over the place trying to find the places
making the heart beat irregularly it has
the highest death rate of any medical
treatment it's called ablation never
never allow a doctor to give you
ablation okay because they kill so many
patients with that one but it's
expensive and so they make a lot of
money with it that's why they go that
direction
you get a good book in the CD it's on
your head follow the directions there
and suddenly after a couple of months
your irregular heartbeat goes away your
heart's happy okay because the skull is
squeezing the tenth cranial nerve the
vagus nerve which controls the right
Rhythm of the heart duh wasn't a hard
problem because now she approaches a
skill problem
so
cells can
read oh absolutely the cells and the
bones ligaments tendons connective
tissue and one of the first ones I was
able to prove very dramatically
was it a great basketball athlete uh
Theo Ratliff 24 years old she was
playing for the Atlanta Hawks he had
terrible arthritis in both knees and the
doctors wanted to give him a double knee
replacement he didn't want to do it
because he you know he'd lose his
basketball career
um he had uh
um arthritis in his hips because the
cartilage was going away he also had
fractures in his right wrist which was a
shooting arm and it took a 35 million
dollar contract away from when he's 24
years old and um
let's see here
and it's one of those things where one
of his colleagues one of his buddy
basketball players okay brought him over
to me we invented what we called the
healthy Bone and Joint pack it was our
basic Healthy Start pack but we had to
come up with a collagen product to
rebuild all the cartilage and ligaments
and tendons and connective tissue and
the bone matrix
and so we used
um
cartilage
okay from beef animals
you know cattle we call it glucogel put
the glucagel with the healthy starter
pack called the healthy Bone and Joint
pack and in three months time he got his
job back and he played basketball
professionally Top Shot blocker top
scorer
he played for 11 years made 100 million
dollars do you think he likes the
healthy Bone and Joint pack
and oh we also made rebound for him
rebound was built for Theo Ratliff
sorry sports drink with 100 nutrients in
it well and Dr well like I have
um one of my Distributors who at 64 was
a marathon runner and he got to where he
wasn't able to go even up and down
stairs at work we got him on the Bone
and Joint pack and within about I think
it's maybe four months five months Max
he was running marathons again
just like he loves the Bone and Joint
pack too just like pant Boone same thing
all his arthritis all the doctors wanted
to give him a double knee replacement
and everything he went our Direction and
he was so happy and excited he wrote the
forward to this book and he tells his
story now we're not talking about a
paragraph we're talking you know half a
dozen Pages he tells his story
of how he beat arthritis now she
approaches using the products from Dr
Wallach okay and so we're so very very
proud that these people are telling
their stories so people can't say oh
well you've got to be making that up
while it can't be true
yeah no I am very thankful to have
documentation like that Dr Wallach it
makes my job so much easier so folks if
you have tried the 90 essential
nutrients and you have
success whether it's a little bit or a
lot I'm all about progress over
Perfection we want to hear about it we
want to hear about it so please go to
daily withdoc.com use that contact
option on the website send us an email
with your experience and what you have
have taken and the benefits that you
have received from it because I know I'm
not the only one Doc and I know we have
lots of coaches on with us here today
who have experienced major positive
just Transformations because they
started giving the body what it
truly truly needed so that it could
actually thrive
now I have another question Dr Wallach
with the 90 essential nutrients can you
get everything that you need from the 90
essential nutrients and the secret
sauces to be able to
rejuvenate every cell in the body or is
there something else that's needed
because I know there's a there's a lot
of different things on the market Dr
Wallach you said something very
important there because we have secret
sauces for specific tissues and specific
cells and specific organs and specific
systems
the 90 essential nutrients okay and how
the brand hard pack
will cover all that
when you have somebody who's really in
deep trouble with a particular uh issue
you want to add more of a certain
nutrient to the system to speed it up
but once they get to where they're
normal
you can eliminate the secret sauce or
reduce it in half or by 75 percent and
just stick with the health abandoned
heart pack by myself
I only weigh 142 and I had terrible
injury which almost killed me I'm in
Canada in a construction site
and
um I which I say I take the two Health
abandon hard packs for months I take a
full dose everything twice a day I take
two doses of rebound a day
and then I also have on my table I don't
know 45
little bottles of all these secret
sauces per liver and heart and brain and
eyes and you know occupative and vision
effects for the eyes and and Prost
effects for the prostate and all this
collagen peptides and all these things
and so I make separate little bottles so
in addition to my uh the
um healthy Brandon heart pack and the
rebound I take all these other things I
I have I make I think 15 to 20 bottles a
week and I take one at breakfast and one
at dinner time and it has all these
pills mixed in there and I take it you
know you've seen me do it I take all
those pills along with all the liquids
and everything and all my food and
everything I've been doing this for over
25 years
okay and so I have to pay for everything
I don't get it for me I have to pay for
it okay so I don't get it for free so
you know I I know that these things
um cost money
and I don't I don't get paid a paycheck
from the company the paper you know I
started the company but I made it so
that I don't get a paycheck so no people
can't say oh well you're pushing all
those vitamins military you get a
paycheck no that's not true okay I said
it purposely
and it's one of those things where
um I just want people to know that
there's hope for them and I'm getting
so many people so many people and of
course you know when it comes to
longevity people say well everybody in
my family has died in their 50s and 60s
oh we got a book for you rare has been
cures chapter 10
okay and of course in in the Biblical
times
everybody knew
that the people in the Biblical times
who live the longest
okay were the ones who lived in the
lands flowing with milk and honey now
being a farmer I want to know what kind
of cows do they have flowing with milk
or goats or camels or are we getting all
this milk well it turns out it wasn't
cow's milk camel milk or goat's milk
that they were having the land flowing
with milk and honey was flowing with
glacial milk and in chapter 10 we have
analyzes of glacial milk from I don't
know a dozen different countries kind of
thing a dozen different glaciers and
they're all different the mineral
content is all different
because the rocks and the clay and the
mountains are all different they're not
all the mountains are not the same and
so there's some of them where they have
more of these essential minerals and
others have less
but it's one of those things where
everybody needs to get this book and and
read that chapter once a month with
their family because it will add 25 to
50 healthful years your life just like
it did in the days of the Bible
when Adam lived to be
930 Noah lived to be 950
um Methuselah lives being 969
okay and there were many many dozens and
dozens of them you know so I'm using
that word dozens not hundreds but dozens
of them who lived the
300 500 600 800 okay and these are the
ones carrying the message of God
okay and they were blessed okay as
growing up in the lands flowing with
milk and honey but it wasn't
cow's milk camel milk or goat's milk it
was glacial milk read chapter 10 of this
book it will blow your mind okay
all right thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach and I just want to remind
everybody that the FDA requires us to
let you know that this program is not
meant to diagnose prevent or cure any
diseases nor are our products but folks
when you give your body what it
absolutely needs
and Dr Wallach through his research as a
pathologist he's got three
post-doctorates in pathology he found
out
all of the compositions all of the
different components that make up
mammals
now he started off with animals yes
and he's done reptiles and he's done
mammals big and small birds and then he
wanted to see how it correlated to the
human body as well and you found that
there was a correlation
there's many of these diseases you find
in birds and when you say mammals we're
talking about whales and porpoises and
sea lions and wombats and
um and by the two years I spent in
Africa that was my first post-doctoral
fellowship with Marlon Perkins the Old
Mission Omaha Kingdom show it's been two
years
um researching why were all the white
rhino dying in South Africa and I got it
figured out that all the farmers are
coming in with the herds of cows and
they were displacing the Rhinos from
their original place where they ruled
for thousands and thousands of years
they're being displaced to places that
didn't have all the nutrition that they
needed and that's why they were dying so
we created more nutrition in those
places and put permanent water in there
when I was there I went there they only
had 350 left in South Africa White Rhino
bit rhinoceros or the the um
Dutch version of the White Rhino bit
renoster and
um I caught 200 of them with a very
strong
restraining drug called m99 is a
thousand no I take that back it was ten
thousand times more potent than morphine
and we could take a little Dart the size
of a triple a battery
and knocked down a six thousand pound
Rhino with just that much drug you know
like a couple of drops of that drug in
that Dart and we'd train them for eight
weeks in a box and then we'd ship them
to America
and
um because they had to be on the ocean
for two three weeks okay so he couldn't
be running around on the ship they had
this in the Box there's a whole time
they were there they'd feed them on the
front end and clean out the back end
and then
um
now today as that last count of last
year okay
um December of last year the count
remember when I was there when I left it
was only like 150 left because we caught
200 of them shipped them out but with
all we did
to eliminate their diseases with their
food sources and water sources and
everything
now there's 21
000 or so so proud of that
well and you can find the story in this
little baby yes Rhino express it was my
first book best-selling book Rhino
Express and it has pictures in there so
it's not just writing there's pictures
it shows the proof of all the stuff we
did for the White Rhino okay there you
go it's it's unbelievable the stuff we
did with those Rhino to save them and so
we're very very proud of that activity
and um
it was one of those things where
uh I cannot thank
Marlon Perkins enough and Barry commoner
who's the head of the Department of
biology at Washington University of St
Louis
because on that project
that helped us get
a 21 million dollar Grant from
from NIH National Institutes of Health
and that was my my big big big Grant
okay the big big one 21 million dollars
from NIH 10 years 20 000 autopsies 600
and something 640 650 species of animals
including humans
and that book
um in a thesis sells new in the box
untarnished still in the plastic
wrappers in the Box sells for twenty
five thousand dollars each
okay you get them online you know you go
online uh go to um
well they can they can find them online
Dr Wallace but let us on the books that
they get
vacations.com
there's another source I'm sure go ahead
no that's the source I want to share Dr
Wally because that's your Source where
because you don't get a paycheck from
youngevity
you earn your living based on the cells
of your book so let's send them to where
one they're going to be coming directly
from you and folks if you want a signed
copy make sure that when you are placing
an order you request to have a signed
copy and Dr Wallach does it I love it
and this is a summary of the 25 000 book
this only costs 25 bucks it's the start
of the new science Deputy genetics the
death of the genetic theory of disease
transmission that's me with one of the
Yorkies primate Center monkeys from the
space Colony okay and I found the first
non-human case of Scyther brosis have
Birds effect thought to be a genetic
effect by megal Dockers proved that it
wasn't and they fired me because they
said it wasn't genetic and that's when I
went back to school and became a
physician so I can't thank him enough
for firing me
absolutely there's good in everything
right doc yeah
well there's also good in having hands
up Dr Wallach so let's go ahead and
start add answering some questions from
the people who are here live with us and
again folks if you are live with us and
you would like to ask a question please
raise your hand find that option in the
zoom menu and how come I can't
oh there we go so let's first go to Jill
Jill go ahead and unmute yourself
hello there hello Dr Wallach
I uh have a question
regarding a customer that I started
recently on the original healthy body
start pack she is 58 years old she's 5'4
she's 218 pounds she came to me wanting
to reduce her pain her overall pain
level specifically joint pains and we
plan to add glucogel but she hadn't
started it yet she did mention to me
that she had kidney issues
um she did her health evaluation
afterwards and later I found out the
extent the her kidney issues she only
has half of one kidney and she's been
living I think since 12 years old with
half of one kidney and she's 58 now so
um about a week or so into the products
she had a routine blood test
for kidney function and she was very
upset because she said her potassium
levels were very high on this test and
she felt that it could lead to a heart
attack so she was wanting to stop the
BTT right aways I do think she continued
on it but with one scoop or maybe even
less in a very slow dose and
I want to know what your thoughts are on
that and
okay well here we go she needs to get a
hair analysis okay so we'll find out
really what's happening okay with a hair
analysis so again she can go to
www.drjy.com I get that book
um let's see here uh rare earth wind
cures go to page
um
272 chapters 10 11 tell you how to cut
the hair how to package it where to ship
it don't forget to put the check in
there because the labs won't run the
test without it
and then it um 58 years old five foot
four
um
she needs and she's 218 pounds she's two
healthy brain and heart packs per month
two photos of a month a full dose of
breakfast for those dinner time with a
health Brandon hard pack says two a
month okay she also needs
um see here you have two vowels a month
of the MSM so you can take three at
breakfast sweet lunch at dinner time
they're gonna rebuild currently's
ligaments tenants connective tissue
discs between invertebrate bone rate
phone itself she also needs to get the
ultimate daily classic countless of
three words ultimate daily classic
tablet so I get two vowels a month so
you take three breakfasts through dinner
time and they will support healthy blood
flow through blocked arteries in the
brain the heart the kidneys even only a
half a kidney and support healthy blood
pressure okay also I would also do
something else for her
um to lose some weight
um what would you do
Becca you're an expert on weight loss
what would you do to help her I I'd
wondered that um five foot four I'd like
to get her down to say 110 120 so maybe
lose 100 pounds how would you help her
do that
well definitely make sure she's getting
enough of the minerals Dr wallet because
minerals are what the buy is missing
most and I know for a fact that Jill is
already an expert on this but getting
those minerals that the body's not in
that starvation mode so that it can let
go of what it doesn't need is a big
thing by reducing the carbohydrates and
making sure that you're sticking with
that good foods bad foods list so that
you're removing anything that's toxic
that helps to or assists in holding on
to the bad things but I love Dr Wallach
the keto diet
adding in the keto shank one a day you
do want to make sure that the rest of
the day you are low in carbohydrates
because it just kind of
you know counteracts when you're not you
can't stress this is a meal replacer
this is not to add to them that's right
yeah that's fine and she did that was
her third Health goal was to lose weight
so she's not opposed to that but how do
I address her very specific concern that
she was on the products a week and her
tests showed high potassium now of
course you know we have no idea whether
it would have shown that whether she was
on it or she wasn't on it but she's very
concerned about the BTT at this point
okay well again if you only have half of
one kidney uh it's hard for these you
know for it to keep up and do the work
of two kidneys okay and so uh she got
drank plenty of fluids
and uh the hair analysis will tell us
the story
okay well tell us if there's toxic doses
of potassium accumulating or if they're
in the normal range
okay so that's what we need is that hair
analysis
okay
okay yep thank you Dr Wallach well thank
you yeah keep us informed and Rebecca
said that keto diet comes in chocolate
and strawberry and again it's a meal
replacer doesn't have to be the same
meal every day
um but um you should say it's um I say
meal replacement is not to be just added
to a meal okay okay
I did already start her on the ultimate
Taylor classic when she told me you know
what was going on so she she had that
under her belt okay good
all right thank you you bet God bless
so Dr Wallach with having that concern
and having the blood work having too
much being high in potassium we don't
want to cut the body off of the
nutrients altogether do we would it be
would it be okay if she just did like
half doses until she got the results of
a hair analysis well if she wants to do
that that's fine okay but she needs to
get the hair analysis fast because a lot
of times for instance you'll see a very
high dose of calcium in people in their
blood and dogs no more calcium no more
calcium
you're dying of a Calcium deficiency and
the calcium level in the blood test is
up here way up there okay because it's
being pulled out of the bones because
the body's receiving that there's
too much when there really wasn't okay
and so everything's all backwards
uh the body is not perfect all the time
the body makes a lot of mistakes and so
you have to uh that's why the you need
the hair nails you get five charts so
two of which are very important one of
which of course is the levels of your
your nutrient minerals and the other one
in this case would be valuable because
it tells you the toxic Metals the metals
at toxic levels
whether it's calcium or Mercury or
potassium or whatever it might be if
there because that second chart will
tell you the toxic levels of minerals
that are involved all right thank you Dr
Wallach let's go to the next hand that
is up and I see that one of our co-hosts
that Sherry is here Sherry do you have a
question
for us
yes I do thank you so much Dr Wallach we
have some amazing listeners and there
are two of them who've sent in questions
one she doesn't have any real health
issues right now but she wants to stay
healthy so what would you recommend to
stay healthy and keep a strong immune
system
okay two things you got to do to stay
healthy keep your strong immune system
number one stay away from the bad stuff
okay no fried foods no processed Meats
no oils no gluten so we burn around oats
even there are no such things as
gluten-free oats the gluten and oats is
called gliadin it's still gluten it's no
buckwheat no sugar no carbonate or
drinks even the diet drinks got to go
and no carbonated water okay you have to
use salt we have the seasoned salt from
Australia okay salt to taste we have the
seed we have the seasoned salt from the
Himalayan mountains where the hunzas are
and their life expectancy is 120. it has
all this uh sea minerals in there as
well as the sodium chloride salt all of
which are essential for the body okay
again uh hair analysis is useful in
these cases again here analysis see
where you're at where you're deficient
if you have too much of something any
place but you need information as
opposed to just saying well here take
this uh that's pretty lame just take
this when there's 90 essential nutrients
involved okay you want more detailed
information to be correct all right so I
hope that helps out there
does the second question is from a
listener as well and this one is
uh they work with clients who have
Eating Disorders they're afraid to eat
more than 300 calories a day because
they're afraid they're going to get fat
she said could this be a nutrient
deficiency or is it just lentil okay
um I want to before we go into this next
one I want to remind everybody to get a
hair analysis you get the book rare has
been cures go to chapter 10 11 and also
put the page the 272 is where it all
starts okay
and then again you want to find out
what's going on
people who are obese
they are
minimally deficient and they develop a
habit called Pica Pica which will lead 8
10 12 15 20 meals a day they're just
constantly hundred I don't know I ate a
meal just a half hour ago when I'm
hungry again eight meal two hours ago
and I'm hungry again I just I don't know
why 8 10 12 meals a day well that's
because there's a behavior called Pica
Pica you can look it up in any
dictionary p-i-c-a and that's just
people that just can't stop eating okay
and animals that behavior is called
cribbing or they chew on the fence okay
they're looking for food okay it's
called cribbing named after the same
thing that happens with human babies in
the crib and they're chewing on that
real and the crib because they're
missing minerals and so they're chewing
on that crib rail so they call it
cribbing and in animals they call it
Pica p-i-c-a okay and that this is why
they tend to be overweight
well how about people Dr Wallach that
refused to eat so it's like the opposite
of somebody that has cribbing
okay okay well people who refuse to eat
um they are which I say they are
obsessive they're afraid of something
and they're prepared
just to eat just enough
chocolate and just enough
um spaghetti and that kind of stuff to
keep themselves from feeling hungry and
they might eat three or four little
small meals the size of a teacup or
something like that a day so they're not
hungry
and
um this is you know obsessive compulsive
Behavior which is a nutritional
deficiency and this is where they need
to be taking all 90 essential nutrients
they held the brain and heart packed
according to body weight now I also like
I'm going to take the synaptics or the
brain cells can talk to each other two
or three of those twice a day the
synaptive I like them to take our I-26
because usually you find when people
have these issues they'll have
um
Ms multiple sclerosis they'll have uh
let's see here they'll have uh f t o d
frontal temporal dementia okay and also
I will have a disappearance of the white
matter in the brain it's called
demolinization okay have all these
symptoms happening because her brain is
losing the white matter in the brain
well the white matter of the brain makes
up 25 of the brain weight and 25 of the
spinal cord weight and
myelin is 100 cholesterol so the brain
is 25 cholesterol and 20 and it's final
quarter 25 cholesterol and doctors are
saying don't eat cholesterol and the
doctors create these problems
by telling people to get off of
cholesterol cholesterol is an essential
nutrient Like Oxygen
thank you
okay
all right thank you Sherry Dr Wallach
let's move right over we have lots of
hands today let's move right over to
Maryland Maryland do you have some
questions for us another one of our
co-hosts here
yes I do hi there um I have a caller um
someone actually wrote in the chat
Anthony he wants to know why all oils
have to be avoided he was talking
specifically about palm fruit oil he
thought was beneficial okay why are you
all bad
okay oils are bad because when they're
stored they oxidize and turn into trans
fats which cause cancer which cause
blockages or arteries it's not it's not
cholesterol it causes blood pressure
arteries it's oxidized fats oils
and salad dressings cooking oils and you
know if you squeeze
um
things like olives you take the the oil
you just squeeze it out of the Olive and
use it as a salad dressing it's perfect
but if you buy a salad dressing in the
store shelf that's been on the store
shelf for a month and it was in a
warehouse for six months at 120 degrees
it's oxidized and it's going to kill you
okay and so
um that's why we have our our efas and
EFA pluses and it's they're made from
um
which I say safe sources
um and we move them very quickly they
have very very short expiration dates so
they don't turn into trans fats okay and
um
it's one of those things where this FTD
is frontal temporal dementia as you know
Bruce Willis has this we've tried
contacting him because we can reverse
that very quickly we can reverse
gambarre syndrome we can reverse
multiple sclerosis we reverse
um all kinds of Dimensions including
Alzheimer's disease okay because this is
just a demonetization it's a loss of the
white matter the brain is spinal cord
okay and um
uh there's probably half a dozen other
demyelinating diseases that we can get
rid of two okay
all right Dr Wallach I'm next we're
gonna do uh pull up Jackie Jackie go
ahead and unmute yourself I see you had
a question in the chat as well so thank
you for raising your hand
hi Dr Wallach um my name is Jackie I'm
67 years old
I'm six feet tall and I weigh about 210
pounds and I have multiple sclerosis for
12 years
and it's starting to progress uh kind of
rapidly the last couple of years where
I'm using a walker now
and I was wondering what you recommend
it okay yeah well this Ms is kind of an
easy one okay because it's a d-mounted
the doctors tell you it was a
demyelinating thing you're losing the
mile in the white matter of the brain no
they didn't tell you what it was they
just said you got Ms okay yes they uh
did a spinal puncture and found uh this
epithelial cells floating in my spinal
column fluid do they do an MRI on you
oh I have them uh every year I have an
MRI and my lesions are stable but I'm
not getting more lesions but I'm not
getting less lesion you know they're not
improving okay so yeah this is this has
to do with demyelinization uh
again we're talking about Alzheimer's
disease uh FTD we're talking about Ms
we're talking about gambarre syndrome
which is ms's spinal cord
and then do you have any Tremors
anything like that no okay good all
right so here we go uh you need to get
rid of all the bad stuff
okay I want you to get a hold of that
book that's called Dr was cooking
without the bad food there's 300 pages
of say for us 300 pages of safe recipes
safe cooking methods and the list of the
good food bad foods okay Dr lunch
cooking out the bad foods then
um you need two healthy branded heart
pressure a month for those everything
twice a day for those breakfast close to
dinner time uh you need to get the MSM
go ahead and to get two bottles a month
of MSM so you take three breakfast treat
lunch at dinner time and they're going
to support and promote Mage repair
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue disc between the right bone makes
your own self you also need to get a
hold of the collagen peptides go ahead
and take a full scoop without your
morning drinks with an evening drink and
then I want you to take our synaptive
take two vowels a month of that sake
take three of breakfast for your dinner
time that's going to help your brain
cells and spinal cord cells talk to each
other okay and I also once you get our
I-26 I would go ahead and have three
servings a day okay I take two servings
a day
all the time every once in a while on
the weekends I'll take three servings a
day but Monday's your Friday I take
three so I take two servings a day money
or breakfast and dinner time
and uh there's they come in chewables
they come in pills and capsules and
powder and so forth let's say I-26 it
rebuilds the white matter of the brain
okay which will help you get rid of
um
Ms Jamboree syndrome Parkinson's disease
if you have Tremors Parkinson's disease
is just Ms with tremors okay because
you're missing
um more myelin in certain places okay
but this is a reversible disease this is
not something you're going to go to your
grave with you do everything correctly
and losing the weight
um you're six foot tall so 210 pounds is
not outrageous okay for somebody who did
you play basketball
yes okay good basketball field hockey
hockey volleyball all right good for you
good for you all right so yeah
let's go there and don't forget our
rebounder sports drink okay we have it
in sticks it has 100 nutrients in it it
looks like this there's 36 in a box and
we have an answer uh 36 servings in the
canister it's powder and then we have
the cans but the cans are carbonated so
you got to pop the tops on them the
night before you're going to drink them
I do that with two
um cans every night before I go to bed I
pop two of them put them in the
refrigerator I drink one breakfast the
other one the second one I'll drink a
half of it at lunch the second half of
the second one I'll drink throughout the
afternoon so I'd have the energy all day
right
because they do have carbonation in them
okay
and so I'm getting 100 nutrients five
times a day
okay and I'm oh yeah so I'll be 84.
okay okay not bad for an old guy
yeah
in school the only sport I didn't let
her in school was basketball because I'm
only
only five foot four yeah okay
all right I did thank you in football
and soccer and weightlifting and all
that kind of stuff well you do have to
maintain yourself yeah yeah
we look forward to being with you for a
long time
well all right I appreciate it
thank you Jackie please keep in touch
let us know how that you are doing yeah
you're gonna have a great story
okay
um I kind of missed some of what you
told me but
um maybe
okay great yes so we are live streaming
which folks after the show you can catch
the replay pretty much any time on
YouTube on Rumble and if you're on
Facebook Facebook so critical Health
news is our Channel Dr Wallach you've
got to get out of here so thank you
again for joining us here we will see
you tomorrow
um back to how you can find the replays
folks
critical Health news on rumble on
YouTube and then on Facebook it's just
critical health so make sure that you're
following us whatever your favorite
platform is follow us so that when we go
live you get that notification so that
you can plug in and easily find the
information that can be empowering and
life-changing not just for yourself but
somebody that you come and count in
contact with somebody that you love
whether it's in your family your
community folks we have provided this
program because we know the value
of feeling good the value of looking
forward to life without having this
label that says we have a genetic
disease and there's nothing you can do
about it you're just gonna have to live
with it and deal with it well that is
fake that's wrong that is untrue
so if we were talking misinformation
there's your misinformation because Dr
Wallach has found that there are over
600 conditions directly linked to
nutritional deficiencies
let's get those deficiencies within you
no longer so that you can thrive
not just survive so if I can get my
co-hosts up with me that would be
greatly appreciated because I greatly
appreciate them they do so much Marilyn
here with us Sherry Ruth Allen today
we've got AJ I'm not gonna forget AJ
because we've he's out there
um in the video land
keeping the comments and questions going
Marilyn does such a fantastic job folks
if you're not here on live with us or if
you are and you don't have that chat
open she is teaching the information
that Dr Wallach is sharing for the
individuals and putting it in the chat
so you can see it in black and white no
you cannot copy the chat but you can
take your phone and do a snapshot of the
recommendation for the products that
really sparked your interest because
maybe you related to that person that Dr
Wallach was giving that protocol for
maybe you know somebody that has the
same type of conditions that the
individual who was on with us today or
any day have that you just have deep in
your heart in your gut know that they
would benefit
share it with them share this program
with them folks if you are here because
somebody
shared this program with you make sure
that you get back with them
thank them for taking the time and
caring enough
to share this empowering information
with you if there is nobody to thank and
you would like to get started on a
program
go to daily withdoc.com we do have a
store there that offers all of the
products that Dr Wallach mentions even
some helpful articles and replays from
our past programming whether it's the
daily with Doc askdoc live ask doc daily
we even have Dead Doctors Don't Lie and
moments of Truth and Q a with pharmacist
Ben which brings me to the next q a with
pharmacist Ben will be Wednesday May
24th at 5 30 PM Pacific time so go to
daily with Doc
or critical Health news make sure that
you're part of our subscriber base so
that you can get that announcement with
the information that is available so you
can join us with q a with pharmacist Ben
we always I love that program I get so
much positive feedback about that one as
well and we'll also be putting some
advertisement up for it on Facebook
follow me on Facebook I've always put
information up
any of my co-hosts reach out to them and
let us know what we can do to help you
find a better health Journey as
certified holistic health coaches we've
been trained in Dr wallick's message his
research using the youngevity products
as the solution to those four areas of
Health that when the deficiencies occur
you have decline you have sickness you
have dis-ease let's stop it and let's
reclaim your life my name is Becca Dukes
thank you so much for joining us here on
daily with Doc you can catch us Monday
through most
most weeks Monday through Friday Doc is
going on the road super excited because
I get to go with him
um so there will be some days that we
will not have daily with Doc but on
those days catch a replay but Monday
through Friday
12 to 12 50 p.m Pacific time that's
California time Oregon time Washington
time Arizona part of the Year part of
Idaho but 12 to 12.50 and then if you're
on the East Coast that's three to 3 50
p.m so join us live on daily with Doc
zoom.com
bye for now
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]